for sure and Google another another one of those those good all of my devices
I don't like in front of me just bled up when I said that okay Google turn the
lights on
hey everyone this is techno geek here just wanted to give a quick shout out to our latest sponsor
project discovery now project discovery makes a lot of tools that you probably know of or have
even used one of them is nuclei and the latest release of nuclei is version 3.2 now 3.2 comes
with a lot of really awesome new features two that I really wanted to highlight here for you
are the authenticated scanning and the advanced fuzzing support now for authenticated scanning it
used to be that you would have to do all your nuclei scanning against unauthenticated endpoints or you'd
have to add your cookies manually all that kind of messy no more it's all automatic you can use
existing login templates to automatically log in to your application and then you can run all your
existing nuclei templates against an authenticated part of the application now to really increase
your coverage the other that I mentioned is advanced fuzzing support now nuclei had added way back in
version 2.8 the ability to fuzz different things but now they've expanded this comprehensively across
the board so not only can you fuzz in the normal spots but you can fuzz within headers you can fuzz
within cookies you can fuzz within specific parts of the body whether that's in json or xml or form data
and so many more things so if you want to learn more about what came in nuclei 3.2 go ahead and
check out the the release blog post over at nux.gg slash podcast that's n-u-x.gg slash podcast thanks
all righty guys I am feeling the podcast energy today man we just got off like a like an awesome
brainstorming session on how to make the critical thinkers discord tier super valuable and now we got
our boy ben back on the pod welcome ben second time hopefully it's better than last time so
nah dude it's that's actually usually we're looking at the podcast analytics and you just see this big
boom this big peak that goes and I was like what is that what is what did we do right there and it's
like ah we had been on the podcast I'm assuming it's probably the youtube uh algorithm loving the
the user and probably yeah it makes sense that was a fun podcast too though there's a lot of like
blind access that stuff and I know I'm looking at the notes for this episode I feel like we're
going to talk more about cross-site scripting anyway so here we are nothing nothing wrong with
a good cross-site scripting man I you gotta love it you gotta love it but but you just um you just
came back from b-sides right yeah b-sides was really really fun um this is our second year going to b-sides
me and jason haddix we host uh the bug bounty village there and nice back again we uh we did an event
with adobe we did some like live hacking events not live hacking event but like live recon more
than anything with adobe and then um yeah I did some workshops and went to some talks and
lots of hackers were in town I don't know if you saw nagli sam and Ian were out there
I saw the pictures man meta facebook's meta's team was there um lots of cool people to see and hang
out with dude I feel like b-sides is just not really on my radar as much as it I mean obviously
you hear about like defcon and naham con and lots of these other you know cons pretty pretty uh
often but for some reason I always forget about uh b-side san francisco so I I think that actually
is one of the more maybe it's just me forgetting about it but I think that is a stealth really really
good conference because I went I want to say in like 2018 and I had some great great talks yeah I
think a lot of the b-side stuff depends on where you are right well besides san francisco it's like
right before rsa happened so but I'm not really like I'm not big on rsa because it's not
it's enterprise I don't have really a lot of stake in that game right but it's cool to go and everyone
comes in for rsa they go to b-side san francisco and then it's like some of the more community stuff
happens there but you also have these like big sponsors that are out there too the cool thing is
a lot is like quote unquote I want to say quote unquote content creators come out so you know like
you see people that are going to rsa for that same specific reason and you just run into them
at the same time it's a very exciting week it's not as exciting as like defcon the summer camp that
we have every year but it makes you like okay I'm almost ready for defcon yeah yeah what what what
kind of so you said you went to some you did the bug bounty workshop which I want to hear more about
but you also went to some cool talks including one by the meta team right and you said you're pretty
impressed with that program right yeah actually so uh farah I've known farah for years and she was at
a bug crowd previously and then she just left and went to meta I think and not recently but you
know she's been at meta for a while now but uh I I just ran into her you know it's like what are you
up to and uh one of our one of the bug crowd folks that was there was like hey let's go see this meta
talk it's supposed to be their bug bounty program and it is mind-blowing to see what meta is doing
with their program dude like I think they're they're top bounded right now is like 300k if you already
see some of their big production sites oh my gosh dude imagine popping a 300k bug that's a you know that's
300k sometimes used to be what HackerOne paid at about at an event in the early days of like the
entire event yeah and then like meta's over here like hey we paid 300k for an RCE and the other cool
thing is I don't know if you guys know they have a loyalty program too you know about that oh oh like
uh like we're gonna have to bleep that but but yeah like the bleep program that you just mentioned
but you know they pay you like they tear you in like different tiers and then depending on what tier you're
on you get a bonus so they were saying like you could probably get you know another 20k bonuses
depending on what tier you are what kind of bugs you find things like that yeah and that they're
doing the promotion for a new bug bounty hunter they gave me a coupon thing I've never submitted
to the meta program but right now if you submit to them you get up to x percent on top of your
vulnerabilities which is really cool dude that I don't know Joel you you've done a little hacking
on meta right that's it's an intimidating target but the payouts are freaking good not a little you
just had a sick xss didn't you yeah yeah okay so yeah we did find an xss on facebook core uh with
some caveats and there is a space raccoon blog post about that um however uh I will say it is a really
cool um you know group of products and platforms to hack on um it's very very dense I think a lot of
the people that hack on that are like specialized sort of hackers like that is what they focus on a lot
of what they do is just hacking on meta products so they're very familiar with the ecosystem and
everything and how it works and how stuff communicates with each other and the common
types of bugs and they have their own gadgets and all sorts of stuff so yeah um I think I think they've
got a cool IOT um ecosystem as well right like the portals and the glasses yeah those and then um
I think they also have a lot of really loyal client-side hackers because they really care about ATO
yeah the ATO stuff is insane dude um yeah one of the things that they were saying with uh their
vulnerabilities also is if you tell them like hey I have this vulnerability and I think I can do x y and
z with it they will give you an authorization from these this time to this time to try it out
and if you can actually prove it to them they'll like do it and then down on top of that they go and
um do their own investigation so if they find more systems that are vulnerable to that vulnerability
with that technique they give you the max payout for that bug this is just all that stuff that
Farrah was talking about during her during her um talk and it it's it's a very interesting program
imagine like you're getting an ssrf on facebook and facebook says cool go out and like show us what
you can actually do with this right wow cool that that's cool that they give you like a time frame
where they're like actively monitoring and like you know sort of figuring out what exactly you can do
um yeah shout out to um jason grace on their team uh he's like a on their purple team and he's like
in between some of the bug bounty stuff he was talking about i think it's he the way he explained
it was very very cool it's like hey i was on a pen test myself and i found a blind xss but i asked him
to let me explore it more and he said i went from blind xss to xxc to rce oh my gosh that's like
something that you don't see most programs let you do that we stop at blind xss like we get critical
payouts for it but i want to pop a show on this admin panel if i can like that'd be really really
cool right oh my gosh yeah absolutely if you can pivot on that that that'd be really awesome get
access to the admin panel and then now you're you're attacking stuff that was never meant to be
external that's pretty rad that they that they let them do that i i really dig that yeah i i know that
there have been a couple hackers recently particularly hackers that are talented in client-side stuff
yeah sort of pivoting over to meta to try to try them out as a as a long-term program because it's
not something you really i mean i say it's not something you do it's sort of uh for a short-term
thing but we we've also had some success i mean joel had some success doing it for an lhe and i've had
some success doing an lhe with them in the past but um i definitely think it's better as a long-term
like this is my home base sort of program where they'll you you know you learn the team they treat
you well you get good bounties you learn the ecosystem i mean if you're spending three months
on like a program like that and you get like a 50k bounty that that's a good return for three
months of work right absolutely i feel like with a lot of like the regular bug bounty programs you
you have to do quantity to make up because of the bounty amounts aren't as high as you would expect
them to be but i think with a big program like that i agree dude yeah i agree you so you mentioned
before you did the bug bounty workshop man can you give me like can you give me the tldr of that i wish
i'd been able to make it out there yeah well unfortunately our we had labs ready and digital
ocean had an incident i think adam caused an incident maybe but he tweeted about saying i
saw him tweet about that yeah i think two other name servers were up and we just couldn't spin up
new things anymore so like last minute we had to change it and i look at jason i go so what do we
do he goes we do what we do best recon i'm like all right so we're going back and forth talking about
like different methods of finding domains and different things you can do we actually talked about
like some of the csp stuff that he talked with you guys about uh at uh b-sides and then we just did a
bit of recon and some tooling and things like that and good turnaround and then uh being a child said
to the adobe team for letting us uh use them as a target for some of our recon stuff sweet was the adobe
team out there yeah they were out there they were doing a lot of they wanted uh i think they're
including fire firefly on their bug bounty program it's they're like uh if i remember it used to be like a
note-taking thing i think now it does more uh so they wanted to get that tested it's like an ai
meets meetings and i think it's supposed to have eventually i saw in the comments like twitter that
they're supposed to be like video editing too very nice very nice that sounds like uh that sounds like
a good workshop yeah there was a new google product that launched that sounds kind of similar to that
too there was google google video i think they call it it's it's like a new google docs google drive
type offering where it's like sheets and and slides and stuff but you it's a video editor that's
based in your browser i wonder if it's like replay where you can like live comment on videos
like you know for editing and things like that or if you can just take it out they they showed a lot
of that kind of stuff where it's you know it's very ai driven and like you know collaboration driven so
you can be like you know let's put this in here and in the same ways that you can collaborate in
google docs and stuff but sounds like an interesting uh hacking target it sounds like to me
yeah for sure and google another another one of those those good home bases all of my devices
like in front of me just lit up when i said that stop stop i'm not i wish you had didn't have
headphones let's go back okay google turn the lights on exactly don't don't don't steal that um
all right man so we've it's been announced it's out there your boys are hosting the hom con
we are super excited for this and we've got some announcements for this week right yeah it's uh
it's an exciting time so people watching may 24 may 25 is the conference we have may 20 30 is with
ctf kickstop 24th we have workshops uh and then on the 25th we have all our main talks and i just
announced on twitter that shoves is actually the keynote uh speaker and he's gonna do some like
laugh bypasses originally it was like smaller laugh bypasses that he was going to talk about
actually like looking at his um cfp right now to see what it was but he's doing
large attack surfaces more than anything else like he's like if you have a large attack surface
this is what you do so some of the things to talk about is like also using tooling using some custom
templates he's gonna talk about like fuff on a single host then add some bird plugins and then he also
has some uh bypasses for smuggling that he's gonna talk about too geez man that guy has an endless
source of content i swear and if that was if that wasn't enough there's also a workshop for two hours
on friday on just waft bypasses with labs and things like that so well with him or with no it's
with him it's uh so yes we hack is one of our sponsors and they wanted to do a talk on it and
there's like it's like an hour and a half and i'm like dude i can't do an hour and a half talk
this is their workshop and they're like yes so i know i don't know about you guys but i get like a
shit ton of tweets that are like hey what is how do i do off bypasses how do i do laugh things dude so
many people and and like i swear because once you get in this industry it's like into content creation in
this industry people will message you and they'll be like hey you know i've got this xss and i can't
get past this laugh and i'm like okay you know i can do this and then i always sit down for like
you know a couple minutes and i'm like let me bypass this thing but i just get tilted you know and i'm
like it's so annoying but there are some there are some you know techniques that that can help with it so
i'm excited to learn a little bit more about that i think there's a good roi for us in particular
with that sort of thing too because we can help all these people dming us yeah i know you guys did some
stuff with um wordpress recently different sponsor but we have a different sponsor coming and doing a
workshop on wordpress hacking actually and like finding bones on uh wordpress plugins how do you
do it and things like that and also there's ctf around there too so i know you guys is critical
thinking uh people that you have on your discord we're really active on that so if they want to
come and do some ctfs you also have that too very good man very good yeah we just actually i want
to say joel earlier today is when we moved the my my wordpress automation script into the for i just
so i had some private automation that i built when i was really into wordpress um plugin stuff uh in the
beginning of this year and essentially it monitors for any plugins entering a certain a threshold of of
uses and it also monitors for common code patterns yeah for vulnerabilities in various um ajax register
functions um within the wordpress code um those that plugin code and then it pushes to a a discord web
hook um whenever that gets in place so essentially over the past couple months i've just i'll just
randomly drop a like a wordpress plugin zero day into the critical thinkers chat and be like here you
go guys just go and report this yeah yeah so that's cool that's amazing dude yeah um but that's not all
within the hum con right like like i i i'm just excited for this last bit there's more you know
we try to keep we try to keep the opportunities pretty clean here on critical thinking you know we
we try to keep the um the things that we talk about pretty relevant and add a lot of value to the
listeners and nothing adds value like 50 000 am i right financial value
yeah a little bit of value so so now we're just gonna jump into it yeah so the another sponsor was
like yahoo and the paranoid specifically and you know you guys have i think probably one of your
first bug bounties was yahoo it was man it was same my my mvh bell was from a yahoo event oh the new
york event yeah yeah uh so yeah they're a sponsor and you know with a lot of our sponsors what we want
to do is like we want to think of like how do they get value and then we do this thing with no
hum con for community i can talk about that later too but how do we make it more fun for the
community while also this like sponsors also happy right so they they i got in a call with
them they're like hey we have 50 000 i go 15 they go no no no five zero in bonuses and i go okay like
that's insane all right like we're doing something big and like yeah like obviously we can't give more
and like we want to like get people to get active what can we do and i'm like okay that's just like
a brainstorm so we brainstorm a lot with them shout out to the paranoids team they were very very good
to go back and forth yeah they're doing some amazing stuff so yeah fifty thousand dollars in
bounties and there is a not bouncing bonuses and there's pretty much a bonus for everybody dude like
anyone anyone that wants to try out this program they can get a bonus you dropped a list here in
the chat let me see if i can pull it up dude there's a critical thinker bonus isn't there so there's one
called the critical thinker there is one for uh there is multiple we don't want to mention everything
but if you have you know if you find something that's critical it's probably going to get a bonus
something with high it's you know depending on the numbers will i find it it might get a bonus
medium like it may get a bonus but there's also like cool stuff like i don't know how long it's
been since you guys have hacked on the bug bounty program it's been a little while for me so if you're
returning you're returning hacker you know you get you ignited with the program you may get a bonus
there is a lot of cool stuff in there so don't uh you know first of all like go find bugs there's assets that are
in scope that are going to get uh bonuses too so don't worry about like hey am i going to qualify
there's so much in there that i feel like everyone could qualify i feel like up to 50 people maybe not
50 people but there's a good 20 30 people that could get bonuses i'm looking at these numbers it's
it may be close to that man because you've got these working out pretty well yeah 37 bonuses right now
oh my god it goes up to it goes up to ten thousand dollars for some and then
uh you know up to 500 for some of the other ones so so here's a little double click into the live
hacking event life for you guys really with with this because one of the um let's just talk about
like one of the more advanced strategies when you uh become like in the live hacking event service or
circuit is how do you optimize these bonuses how do you hack on these targets not only that are are
going to be getting you bounties and getting you enough bounties but are also going to land you these
bonuses that companies just kind of throw money at these specific assets so um this is this is a
cool opportunity to kind of feel what it feels like to have uh these bonuses tacked on like we
get at the life hacking events all the time and funny you say that that's literally when i sat down
i was like how do i come up with 50k bonuses you know like how do we do this so it's like more fun
for everybody i'm like how do we do that life hacking events you know how do we do it where you just ask
and you just pretty much think of like what are what are some of the cool bonuses that we had at
these events and there it is so there's gonna be more information on this coming out soon i think
by the time this podcast comes out a lot of it's going to be announced uh but yeah if you're watching
this if you're a critical thinker you're someone on their discord if you're on if you're watching this
not even on discord at all you know you can hack and it doesn't have to be on one platform either it
could be on either platform that the yahoo program is hosted on too it's pretty sick dude pretty sick
opportunity lhe stuff brought to the public here very good dude um i i i really i really do also
like the uh the reigniter thing like the people that used to be engaged with the yahoo program and
want to come back because they hold a lot of knowledge right in their heads and in their you
know inbox about the yahoo program and you can kind of bring that back in and reignite your your
engagement with that program it's the same thing with the hacking events so you invite some of your
top hackers because they have you know value and then they get invited to the program for the
events right so that's kind of the same idea um but joel do you want to give us one more but wait
there's more but wait there's more there's one more thing uh more value i think and then also i i'm you
know i think with with education content creation i think going to vegas i had a friend of mine that i
will keep anonymous but this person didn't want to stay for defcon one year at h1702 and it's like
hey you should just stay we'll get you a room just stay and hang out and he he went to h1702 and so
he went to defcon and he was like oh my god this is so cool like i wonder why they would done this like
i met so many different people that kind of like energized me and i'm like super excited about it
and i never expected any of that i just i want this person to just stay and hang out more and
this year you know we thought about like okay if this person calls me and tells me like hey that was
really valuable for me and they're already in the industry they've done you know vegas every year
because of their job or whatever it is what do we do for someone that has never had the chance to go
to defcon so as a part of the partnership with yahoo also one person is going to get a full ride
scholarship to go to defcon so which is uh your your flight and hotel being paid for i don't think
there's going to be like food and stuff like that unfortunately but the big lift is on us you know
we're going to book you a flight we're going to book you a room uh hopefully get you a badge
and you get to go and enjoy defcon uh from thursday through sunday and have a blast and
hopefully make some you know make some friends do you think we can sneak them into h1702 as well
that is a really good idea i'm working on maybe also you know getting that other half of their week
and like because i think it's a really cool thing to go to h1702 yeah especially if you're bug bounty
hunter already right 100 man that adds so much value i think if me and you both pull out the puppy
dog eyes on on caitlin or jessica we might be able to make it happen so i i know that i know
they watch these podcasts so caitlin jessica ari and uh harley you guys are watching this we are
gonna beg you please let us make this happen but honestly please but uh yeah i haven't thought about
that forest there's a little bit of logistic nightmare with bringing someone to h1702 because
it's somebody's event the customer the client and then yeah they're gonna have to leave for the nda
stuff and stuff like that so and then the community parts of it also like people are very entitled to
some opinion sometimes but we'll see uh to be determined we'll know in like a week or two maybe
we'll announce that in the hong kong who knows very cool man well i am super excited either way it's
gonna be a blast and uh really looking forward to all that whoever whoever lands the um and and this
scholarship this is for people that performed well in the yahoo challenge right it's it's gonna be at
random we're not gonna say you know it's not just performance space so you don't have to be the top
of the tier hacker it's just we want someone that's gonna put in the effort so there is a little bit of
effort there so you have to get some sort of a valid submission and then at random we're gonna pick
somebody that's gonna want to go to this event and then the first person says no we go to the next one
the next one until someone says yes very solid man it's gonna be like the real lhe experience you got
bonuses you got free flights free hotels a bunch of community we just don't have a belt that's awesome
on the home no harm sec belt and just just take one of the belts and like just paste your face over
it that's good man so that's all of it so for people i want to get involved even if you don't
want to go to defcom there's a lot of money for grabs please like go and hack on yahoo and make
some money and that's addition to what you would get on those bounties too it's crazy i i'm super
excited for naham con this year it's going to be it's going to be a uh a record-setting one man i
think in the history of naham cons um it's our fifth year so we got to go out with the bank dude for
our fifth year got to go got to go hard um so let's go ahead and shift the conversation let's go
talk about some some technical stuff um we got some cool csp stuff and we got some ci cd stuff where do we
want to go we can start with i think sarah city would be cool because we can also talk about a little
bit of a launch on some stuff you guys have on your notes but yeah oh yeah that'll be that'll be real
fun i so all right let me let me start with that then just just to give to give lupin his his due
here so um our boy lupin came on the pod we did an episode with him in uh in japan uh and that was
one of my favorite episodes to record to be honest because one he's got so much passion and his accent
sexy and the backdrop of that episode was really good um so one go check out that episode two
of ways launching a product and it is a freaking amazing thing that has uh sort of stemmed from
this whole ci cd research that man i guess this whole dependency confusion thing stemmed from a live
hacking event where aj chapman um and and uh not not i'm sorry alex bearson um and i were working on
bearson did have i have a a uh or chapman did have a part of that event but it was a different thing
um alex bearson and i were sort of working on paypal related bugs and this whole dependency
confusion thing came out um and then you know lupin sees this and he's like this is a crazy
industry a crazy scoper surrounding ci cd stuff and he's built this tool called depi um that he's going
to be releasing and this is an enterprise product to help secure the uh ci cd chain and i've seen this
thing all right dude hold on let me send let me send you this link this link is not public yet
um but you got to go to this link and tell me i saw the website dude i saw did you see it okay yeah
it's a pretty pretty interesting design it's a very cool design it's very unique it's i know he's worked
really hard on this uh because i you know him and i chat once in a while he was one of the people that
reached out to me when i went to my burnout and would just go back and forth a lot it's like
i'm so slammed with making this happen and then when i saw this side i'm like holy crap this is gorgeous
yeah dude it's it's an amazing product and it's also just technically really interesting because
he's been kind of keeping me in the loop while he's doing the research that that powers this thing
and he's got so many like zero days in all of these package management softwares that he uses to get
this sort of dependency confusion um and uh and so i'm really excited for that for that to launch uh
and i just wanted to give it a shout out here because it's a product that i really really believe
in so if you haven't haven't checked out ci cd stuff definitely check out um it's at www.l and
h.tech.deppy it will be live by the time this podcast is live uh so we can go ahead and shout
it out yeah very cool stuff i'm excited to see what he does with it and i'm sure he's gonna have
a lot of like a research come out of it too with this being released yeah we're gonna we're gonna
have him on for an episode in a couple weeks to talk about the technical details of that which i'm
super hyped for but you've also been doing some ci cd stuff right mine isn't so much like the
dependency confusion stuff mine is just mostly on these couple of pentests that i've been on
um it's always like hey we want you to do a pen test but we're not gonna give you credentials
to start with it's like great love it like it's it's a phase one right but what do you do like
there's so much you can do with javascript files and if it's like if they're using some like
framework like say like django or something right then your chances are going to be a lot less you
know django is just an example but like whatever phv framework or whatever language they use so you
gotta just really think about it but i just it all started with just like a dot get ignore file with me
there was like four assets in scope and it just started with like a dot get ignore file that
leaked a lot of like paths and i'm like if they have this file on here like i wonder what else is
on here too right like what else can i find on these other apps that they own so so wait the dot get
ignore file you were looking at that for things that they didn't want included in the github repo but
might have been accessible via a web server somewhere yeah so if you could get ignored it's like for
tracking like it's like it tells you like hey ignore these files you don't track them right and sometimes
like they'll have like folders for like logs they'll have like their upload folders in there
and it's just they don't want to change it or they don't want to track it um the upload ones like
interesting if you can find some stuff the logs ones are interesting but then like at the bottom
there's also like configuration files sometimes right this one specifically one of the the companies had uh
i don't remember what the path was but they had like their gitlab ci files in there like you can see
all the different repositories they work with and you can you can look for dependencies and confusions in that way
right but then it gets worse when they have like a uh config.json file in there and it has like
credentials inside you sort of think about like hey if there's like getting ignored as one of them
you can't rely on like a all.txt word uh wordless right you can't just throw everything at it you need
to be very specific of like hey what does gitignore used for what does gitlab ci uh yaml file for and then
finding specific names that are similar to it and that's like where ai becomes super super handy dude
mm-hmm yeah no i could totally see that it that that that technique is not one that i've actually
super thought about and i wonder if you could take if you could find some way to correlate
github repos to the what you're seeing on a web server like you create a tool that correlates that
either through like the dot git file being exposed or something like that and then create very high signal
alerts where you download the dot getting nor file you pull the paths down hit the web server on those
paths and then if any of those come back you assume that that's going to be super interesting
which i imagine yeah and the other thing is like if they're using some you know one tool on this asset
what other tools are they using on the other ones like if they have a config.json on this one like
what are some other like files that could be a json file that has credentials inside of it
i think the other thing is like we can't think of those names i don't know if you guys are like
that but i can't think of those things when i have this like rush of like oh my god i found this
what else can i do yeah tunnel vision on the same file name um so that's when like something like a
ai giving it that's reservoir has a really good uh command that hits uh gpt and then it pulls like a
list of files based on what you give it to you give it like six files name file names like yaml files dot
files and config files and go hey give me 50 more and then some of those hit on some of the other web
assets that they get dot get ignore wasn't accessible right i don't see a lot of those anymore but the ones
that you see that bug binding programs don't see them because everyone's running templates now and
doing boot forcing and things like that but once in a while you still see them pop up it's interesting
to dig into yeah yeah i bet with the with the i guess popularity increase of nuclei you're you're
you're not seeing as many of these like dot dot get files being exposed and stuff like that and
in any meaningful way i'm curious to see how people write a nuclear template for a dot get ignore file
because there is nothing that's like identified in the headers they can say this is a dot get ignore
file there is no like unless you find a word dot yaml in there maybe but that's like very
i don't know i think it could be a false positive it's hard to fingerprint right ah
yeah that's true i also think that whatever you do with with um you know mass recon i think
it's a whole nother sector it's a whole nother distribution to do that one layer deeper
right so like let's say for example you're scanning for dot get everywhere right um there's
hundreds of people doing that but there aren't hundreds of people hitting gao hitting way back
running a quick hits a brute force list taking that first layer of paths and then running all
those nuclei templates on under those paths as well and i think i think that's there's a lot of value
especially with like apis and stuff like that too right if you like people hit like slash
actuator on api so they don't think about doing api or like api app names api and going down every
folder and you see a lot of more a lot more of those than you see on like the web group
absolutely yeah just as we continue to talk about recon stuff what every time you're
oh do we lose them come back sorry this camera is weird stuff sometimes
that's fine um as we continue to talk about recon stuff i uh i i always sort of dream about building
some scanner that can effectively check for path traversal problems essentially where you can
and i'm sure stuff out out there exists i just haven't really figured it out yet but i i remember
finding an rce one time on www right and i just all all it was was in on a pretty well-known site
dude like this is a household brand that that's paying you know i think it was like 6k crits at the
time and it's go to www do dot dot dot dot semicolon slash and then you get access to this back end
piece and you can just so there was like nothing else but like a dot dot semicolon slash no it just went
straight from there and so i i keep on thinking like there has to be a good way to fingerprint
where these traversals are happening like you should be able to do just a normal dot dot slash and then
compare it to a dot dot slash 2f or a dot dot you can do the response size you can compare and if it
comes back as like a 500 or something that you ignore it but if it's like a 200 there's probably
something there if it's normalizing correctly like you take something that of course it's going to
normalize correctly and then you know try to do these permutations and if they aren't the same
then you can say okay well these actually should be the same response so something sketchy is happening
here i don't know it's probably it's probably really hard to get to be high signal but i feel like i feel
like there should be some way to do it i think it's going to be difficult to know what's garbage and
what's not in a lot of these cases like what is actually a result that you want versus like an error page or a random page you don't really care about
yeah yeah for sure all right man um last last little topic we had this is going to be a quick
little pod today because we we spent so much time brainstorming about about content creation stuff and
in critical thinking steer stuff um but i did want to hit on csps related yes yeah so you mentioned in
here you you've got some csp bypasses for uh for google maps um and some other google products
actually so why don't you talk a little bit about that because um i love these i love that these
things exist these are such good little gadgets to have so yeah i think google itself is just a gold
mine for bypasses like one of the number one things i look for is youtube and google when it comes to
csp bypasses youtube is i think my favorite one actually last time i was here i talked about finding an
xss at a live hacking event and that company had a really hard csp bypass and youtube was the one
that works so with youtube actually for people that are watching maybe we can talk about you know how
csp works uh it pretty much allows you to call scripts objects images files from trusted sources uh they
say is to prevent multiple vulnerability types but i i say that's bs it's probably for excesses mostly
uh yeah more than likely for modern applications i don't know i feel like you can do and and this
last episode that we discussed with um with johan he just gave such a beautiful um deep dive into
uh csp related stuff and and there are a lot of things you can do with it like
the form action related thing can can prevent you from doing um when you don't have specific when you
don't have access but you can create these forms and sort of do a a c-surf or a c-surf token leak
that can definitely be helpful but uh and then obviously of course you've got anything that
that's relating to like um uh cross-site leaks it can also be limited by by csp but certainly the
primary function of it is to prevent cross-site scripting which is really tricky to do when all
these sites keep on like having all these gadgets in place that allow us to pop stuff yeah so i think
the youtube one is one i think uh you had one listed for um google for maps yeah so so maps this
one i have to give credit where credit was due i meant to mention this on on the pod with johan and
maybe we sort of uh shouted it out but i want to say that that was actually a tweet coming from him
joel do you know if that's if that's right i don't remember yeah i i want to say he tweeted out a couple
weeks ago uh a a uh google like maps.googleapis.com um bypass a csp bypass that is done via json p right
um because one of the most one of the most common ways to bypass csp is to find an endpoint where
they're utilizing json p um and then actually insert a full function call into the callback
um and so we we've i showed this one to ben on on the pre-recording and ben's like oh yeah i got like
a couple of these and he pulls out one for www.youtube.com www.googleapis.com www.google.com
i assume there's also another one for accounts i can't find it but it's like if you hit the oauth
on google.com it's like a callback function you can do the same thing i'm gonna find that eventually
because i just used it recently but there's also that i think it also goes beyond that too like this is
only when the companies allow you to do google they allow you to do youtube or they allow you to
do like whatever waft they use or you know whatever companies that they're they're trusting right but
there's also like the json p thing is also on their end if they have an oauth floor you can hit or if
they have like some random uh json p that you can find it's a it's a really interesting it's a very
creative and one of the first things i like to do is like always just do a site on google dorking site
site.com and then looking for callbacks for example and you don't get them a lot of
times but there's a bit of few times you can find them and it's really really really useful
and and these are pretty widely i feel like when you see a csp they're often like all right start
out google.com or start at google.apis.com or something like that so having these json callbacks
on these really trusted domains is super clutch so we'll we'll um we'll put these in the description
of the episode we'll drop them in that in the hacker notes as well we'll probably tweet them out
so you should see them in many places if you follow critical thinking in any way but um thanks for
sharing these man because these are uh definitely high value gadgets to have in the in your back
pocket for sure yeah absolutely and we're gonna be for the critical thinkers soon soon we're going to be
putting together some sort of potential reference or collection of these gadgets for these types of
things so that uh you know as you're hacking as you're going through and you're sitting there and
you're one step away from an awesome bug and you're like dang if only i had a csp bypass for
blank well now you're you have a reference that you can come check and you can come see if somebody's
already got one uh that they shared with you so stay tuned for that because uh we're going to be
working on the critical thinker myself i'm looking forward to guys so
yeah that's great man that's that's really good and i i guess i just wanted to shout out this this
isn't in the doc so we're going off off the thing there but um there was a really cool piece of
research that i just can't get out of my head um which was essentially a scenario where you can't do
this or with like the full csp bypass right where you can't do like a full function call in the callback
but you can do um you do have something that that triggers javascript so you're able to trigger some
it just doesn't allow you to do a function call and um and so what this guy did with his research
that i saw was he would include a script right like script dot uh you know whatever and he would do
like as his as his callback he would do opener dot child element child element child element child
element child element right so these are all just dots and ascii characters which are all allowed in
the callback even secure callbacks and then obviously it's doing some sort of function call at the end or
else it wouldn't be a json p callback so he ends it with dot click and then in javascript you can pass in
any parameters to a function even if it doesn't take it and it'll just kind of like shove them away
um so then what he would do was he could click arbitrary buttons on a page that was uh the opener
of that page so you you do a window.open you redirect your original page to like an oauth flow
and then you include that csp which will do go down on the parent page and click the approve button for
an oauth flow or something like that and approve your oauth application and i'm like this is such
a genius technique to be able to weaponize just one single function call to execute on a parent page
how do you even like think of that i don't know man but when i read that i literally sat there with
my jaw open for a while because i'm like wow um now you don't even really need a a full csp bypass in
order to get some impact because sometimes you see these json pn points and you can't
you know introduce a function call or anything um so i'll see if i can track down that research and
i'll put it in the show notes um for for this one because i i think i cannot give that i've mentioned
it on the pod before but i cannot give that research enough shout outs how creative yeah i would love to
really understand how they did it once there's been a couple of times when i have been stuck with like
these callbacks where you can do a function uh there's a couple other things too like when you can't
do parentheses sometimes for some reason but you can do like the tack the backwards is also one but it's
just makes it back ticks yeah it makes it a lot harder to exploit though but that's only if you're
desperate for an alert of some sort of to demonstrate it right seriously and and i think actually the
cool thing about the research that he mentioned as well was i think by default every wordpress site
has that gadget built in that that you can't do the you can't do the full function call on the callback
but you can do this thing that he's describing so um it's super easy to find a uh like a a wordpress
site on any of these victims right like most of them have them have them set to like slash blog or
something like this and then it reverse proxies to a uh to a wordpress site so lots of uh really
awesome gadgets there as well awesome all right man i joel i know you got a hard stop right now um
um ben anything else you want to shout out no shout out to you guys for bringing me on this podcast
and then also hosting the home con and hopefully uh the expectation is met with all the the hype that
we're building on the home this year oh dude it's gonna be it's gonna be freaking great i'm sure
the schedule is live so they can go and check out check it out and then just a reminder may 24th
may 25th is the main conference awesome and that's where can they where can they check it
the home con.com go to the home con.com there's a schedule on there you'll see everything that's
happening just on their website all sweet awesome that's a wrap on this pod i think peace everybody
and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for listening and if you
want more critical thinking content head over to ctpb.show slash discord join the discord there's lots
of great conversations and chats going on over there and if you want to support the show there's
the discord subscriber tiers which give you access to master classes amas hackalongs exclusive scripts
and an exclusive chat channel with us we'll see you there